hey everyone
very pumped we are still at the
incredible shift into
permanent alignment event
of bentino massaros here in beautiful
costa rica
we are now going to be talking to
another one of the
epic retreat attendees gilad gorbonos
hello
yes i've had such a blast hanging out
gilad he came from israel all the way
here
it's a big commitment quite a journey
yeah and how many years have you been
following ventino's work
yes three years me too yeah me too
i'm really interested in many topics
with gilad he
understands the depths to the nature of
reality
in the simplicities of it and so i'm
pumped for this conversation
and it's also really interesting topic
that we'll refer to throughout
free will is god
very interesting tell us a bit about how
you got
interested in spirituality in the first
place
so you know life
just led me to
to seeking to seeking happiness to
seeking love to seeking
truth basically seeking like the harmony
within
which expresses us the harmony
outside also and
i was going through this pretty painful
break breakup
like six years ago and i went to india a
little bit after and i just met this guy
who didn't just speak up because of the
camera microphone
yeah yeah just met this guy
ended up being my teacher for a week and
he initiated me into yoga
he gave me like the the
sort of transmission sort of like
initiation into
just direct seeing of what yoga is
before even
did yoga like did the postures and all
this stuff
so maybe i did a little bit of that but
he just told me yoga
is the celebration of truth and
and that sort of like sent me officially
to the journey
[Music]
of discovering discovering
within myself
verifying
the natural state experience verifying
the
causeless state of being
of
you had a seeking impulse for happiness
and also you had the suffering catalyzed
by your breakup
and then your travel to india and
the which guru did you sit with
it's not exactly a guru a guy a very
simple guy
i love it just a simple guy yeah yeah
yeah
big smile and
[Music]
and it was just sharing was sharing the
knowledge within
the knowledge wasn't only in the words
the knowledge was alive
yeah yeah when
knowledge and two knowledge is
transferred it's
awakening within the being it's
unfolding flowering from within and
the confirmation for
the truth or the relevance or the
effect of this knowledge within is is
the bliss
it's the yeah it's the feeling of
happiness it's the feeling of lightness
it's the feeling of
just electricity yeah dance to the
system and it's like
the plug got in
and now it's closed to set it
yeah so that's a good point is that the
way that you know
about awakening is bliss it's
a good measurement is the natural state
being a
blissful state of just life itself yeah
okay and what was a specific do you
remember a specific
pointing that was shared with you that
was
a very aha moment from back then
i remember it was mostly around love
around starting to
discover to see what true love
is about what uh what's the essence
of this of this love of what everyone
seeks basically
in externalities in phenomena
in experiences
and
i remember he said that love
is sacrifice
sacrifice it was quite a mystery for me
back then it resonated
but today i see it much
and does that play into the service to
others
idea not only it's first and foremost
it's the sacrifice of
one's own ideas
about oneself about life one's own
perspectives and attachments yeah and
yeah perceived benefit
in things
so this sacrifice has a purifying effect
yeah and the result of this purifying
effect
and also the process itself yeah is love
and also the origination point so love
is like the whole
embracing principle so interesting
so yoga or union with god or the
absolute
can be thought of as leveraging
love as an alchemical tool
which then we feel bliss and peace
on the other end yes cool yes
yes exactly it's
it's there on all parts of the
of the journey in the beginning in the
middle in the process and in the end
it's the same like origination point and
end point
yeah yep
wow you see so totally
so yeah that that also bridges the the
gap
that is generated in the mind between
here and there and
yeah i'm here and i'm not there and
[Music]
she started tasting non-duality yes
yes and started testing myself yeah
yeah tasting myself beautiful yes yeah
yes beautiful the capital
s and also the possibility
the you know because until we know
that something is possible it's not
on our letter it's not not
interesting it's not
maybe it's like on the riser you know
like you heard about it somewhere but
until you really know yeah you verify
yourself if you experience you
have the proof that it's possible and
it's probable
and it's likely when and
it's real it's still once you test it
they see the reality of it you see
the invitation that that lies
is present in this possibility so then
it's like the incentive
to keep deepening
keep seeking keep opening new doors
to yourself and it's not like you open
them just by this
belief that it's possible plus the
desire that starts to awaken
the will to go further by itself
opens up the doors that life
provides with the doors with the keys
with the
pictures yes
all catalysts yeah
yes beautiful yes in different uh shapes
and forms
and to be able to have that subtlety to
see
all of those catalysts as
capitalists is really important
because our receptivity our sensitivity
our subtlety to that
determines how quickly we recognize the
true nature
when did you go to india how many years
ago
i've been there quite a lot in the last
[Music]
five six years um cool last time was
last year
beautiful yeah beautiful
and so then you continued sponging up
different spiritual teachers spentino
being one of them
you continued picking up some of these
different literatures from the
mystic traditions this type of stuff yes
okay yes and also
as you said teachers the presence of
i would say realized beings or beings
that
know that no that's that have seen
very deeply and
very deeply integrated this truth this
teachings so
in my experience that's a very important
and
accelerated way to sort of
receive the teaching which is beyond the
words
so the teacher
knows can what the being
knows
is the ability to
radiate the knowledge and the seeker the
student who is open
who is willing who is ready to receive
can very instantly
see see for himself not
not to the words to the concepts and the
filters but
see directly
so this is how it unfolds and
it's beautiful because that's the
exchange
that we're experiencing on the planet of
teaching and learning and learning and
teaching and
so they're all in a sense
teachers of each other and students of
each other and for life
so yeah in my opinion that's a very
maybe the most effective way to
to receive this knowledge uh of yoga of
truth
uh directly from other realized beings
yes or to a being who has embodied
that integrated to a high extent yes
rather than in books and stuff like that
which is also good way
beautiful but it takes a very high
degree of
commitment and practice like uh
persistent determination to get it sort
of like
yeah by yourself yeah yeah it's very
it's very possible but it takes
totally takes a lot of will and
readiness
to it yeah yeah and also exposure to the
right teachings
the important teachings that's right 7th
yeah discernment earnestness
which has to do with that seeking
impulse
dedicating oneself full time to that
i like how you prioritize being in the
presence of
fully realized beings that have it very
deeply
radiating from their essence so it's not
just the words
but it's also the bliss and joy
and peace yes you can feel eternity
emanating from them but that's the thing
once you
are there and you see it and you feel it
you are being it so it's
not from them correct correct it's from
you that's that's the revelation yeah
yeah and you are that serving yourself
yeah yeah yeah so the being there is a
lot of appreciation gratitude for this
being and
and there is like relationships
or connections love
great love for for these beings yeah
but it's seen very clearly also
it can be seen very clearly that
actually you and the teacher
the essence is one the i love it there
is one
dominator there's one first there's one
yeah
which we could say is truth
that's one way to put it there are more
like also direct and practical ways
and the most particular is just present
so
there you go
energy also another way to put it a bit
less direct
presence energy yeah that's a
combo that you can put like this i like
the idea of it being like a radiating
sun as though the
truth when it really is anchored inside
of the
realized being it radiates like the sun
the bliss piece the
eternity infinity
nothingness everythingness
compassion love
and getting it directly
it's going straight to the source the
book
is
in videos are good
but you're probably pointing to
something really important right now
which is that
it might be the best
to go in for the in person
yes because the teacher is embodiment
is an extension is
like an angel agent of this office of
the sun
yeah is a representation of the sun
within a form of a human being
perfect yes the sun is never radiating
the sun is over there the sun is
effortless the sun is
yeah or if i say the sign is
light yeah it's light yes
oh it's essence so effect is light
yes
so in the same way
a human being can serve
can function like this principle of
ever radiating
sun light yes perfect
emanating force of
enabling of illuminating
both perfect
radiating and
how much illumination do you catalyze
versus endarkenment
is that the question just a way for
people to
potentially recognize endarkenment could
be something like the
ego and having
seeking peace and happiness in the world
trying to extract it from experiences
and other people
and substances and wealth and sex
and all that type of stuff versus
enlightenment in many ways
the illuminating aspect of the sun
shining through a being is very much
like
not only the service to other but it's
the essence of love
itself and so
it's kind of interesting putting it into
the perspective of the dual
enlightenment versus endarkenment yes so
as you say it's dual and as i said
the sun is the enabler
of what you call endocrine or
darkness or shadow so yes this
shadow aspects of ourselves of
the human being the mind
enabled by the sun existing
only because of the sun the sun
is what giving
birth what's giving existence
to this shadow so this darkness
is so perfect perfect so the sun is like
the background
and when the light is on
the shadows can be seen through
so you have the context of the light
whether it's not there's the darkness
but the darkness is like a
spot a point on
it's in the sky or a cloud
appearing in the sky yeah the sun
is the ever present undercurrent
and then there's the
which makes also the endarkenment
possible
the light is what makes the endarkment
possible in its little journey in this
creation
we have much we have much more to talk
we have so many other subjects that i
still want to talk about so
let's let's actually jump is that okay
yeah
sure okay so i want to lay out
i want to lay out something here and i
want then for you to hit the tennis ball
on it so
the magic stick yeah the magic stick
okay so
we're both passionate about
the law of one and in many ways
it gives a very clear distillation on
our metaphysics on the nature of reality
and so
we as the creator go
through a process of play
with this creation
which undergoes this ascension
style process in getting to know itself
better
and we are at a point
in that process and so we're eternally
doing this but we're just talking about
this
one that we're exploring right now
where we're at a point of
very clearly a
a matrix that is captivating
consciousness in
the dynamics that are visibly
absent that we've been talking about
throughout this conversation
and then there's also the juxtaposition
or the contrast of that
which are the dynamics that we've been
talking about which can be thought of as
the next
density of evolution that service to
other style mentality rather than the
service to self-style mentality
and free will plays a big role in that
process
the role you know yeah that's a key
element
that's the the i would say the ultimate
bridge
or even the one and only bridge in that
process
of awakening individual awakening
and collective global awakening
so that's the swiss one that's
that's the essence the the will
the will and many people uh have
confusion or have a
misunderstanding because of
acquired and the knowledge information
about this concept
but actually the wheel of free will is
as i said is very simple and practical
direct and also intuitive
and experiential
reality
it's a concept but points to it enables
a direct penetrative
experience of freedom and truth
and of more of ourselves of harmony of
healing
of shifts within ourselves instead of
being in a
mental makeup
in the manifestation of our lives other
events and circumstances so will
choice is the
dominating factor
to more pure levels of understanding
more pure
way of being of interacting
knowing oneself in this life
so will the will is inherent
within ourselves it's inherent within
creation
it's the very substance which is we can
say
things are made of things are enabled by
things are possible through
by this this will this desire of
creation itself the creator to manifest
to appear to experience itself
as everything as the the monkey
as the human being as the
but within a human being this will
appears as a choice something that can
be
conscious that can be used it can be
cultivated it can be
activated
and can facilitate and
greater awakening greater accumulation
of
consciousness densities of density of
consciousness of
light within oneself and therefore truth
and liberation
so the wheel is the gateway to the
natural state
the natural state and
you can define natural state natural
state is the state
of life as it is
life as it is of some
call it the dao the effortless
manifestation which is totally
aligned with the central intelligence
with source yeah with the original
logos which
runs the show it's your manifestation
so the wheel is the gateway back to that
natural state it's
the natural state is already the case
but we
because of programming because of
conditioning
that apparently apart
from this natural state we
we've been taken to a distorted
state of mind state of being
which got the momentum
and became a reality became solid
became the life the world
myself and others and society
and all of that stuff so
this is a very powerful momentum this is
like this is a river of
of ignorance of samsara of
the matrix which just runs you know and
it takes
whoever is connected it takes it with
everyone knows it's
the conditioning the i should do this i
should do that
all of the structures and
ideas and the social agreements
so in order to wake up to
disconnect from this from this grid from
this metrics
from you know to awaken one needs to
start swimming against the current
and the swimming against the current is
the awakening of wheel of
choosing otherwise
[Music]
and it starts with a mental decision but
it gets much deeper it gets to the
deepest
place within oneself which is
the consciousness the
deep awareness the
the essence of oneself and of life
so the will is being cultivated the
choice
and is being revealed to be much
deeper than the regular way we perceive
wheel is like i want this i don't want
that i go here i go left i go right and
the the wheel which is filtered to
to the mind to identity
and in a very like intuitive level or so
this is an important clarification
there's a will
that's filtered through the mind versus
a will that's used with consciousness
and it is consciousness and is
consciousness yes
yes okay yeah the will that is
consciousness
is different than the will filtered
through the identities of the mind
the layers of the mind because that
will is more
impure it's also more
limbic or primal or algorithmic
the weight of the mind yeah yeah and
then it's more like a
machine like a machine yeah there's
input and outputs
and then so once you start getting
bentino in the last days been using this
analogy of these
10 000 little ice cubes
of will that are shipped into
little freezers across the planet and
then
we go over time and acquire more of
these
little will ice cubes and then
as we sort of melt that down
we become more air-like and we become
more water-like
we activate more of the consciousness
will
yes exactly okay keep going exactly
breaking
the automatic conditioning the automatic
mind
and bringing light to the unconscious
the death which operates us
which is collective and individual it's
being acquired
it's been acquired in from the society
from the parents from
experiences throughout life so
that usually runs the show of one's life
the reactions the motivations the
desires and the fears and all of that
so wheel is actually the willingness to
see through that to bring light
yeah to to oneself to start inquiring
into
oneself and okay so self-inquiry
creates more will
yeah it generates generates it's like
spiritual mass is what bentino has been
calling it
yeah yeah it builds the energy it
generates space
for for this for this world for this
process to
[Music]
to continue deepening
yeah so
it's like creation cannot be stopped
everything just goes on no pause button
no pause no way out
and this is the wheel it's anyway the
case the wheel anyway
is anyway the case we can only sync with
it we can only
be more like it like like this inherent
intelligence in creation which operates
everything
you can see in nature you can see in the
in the plants and
animals okay let me play the with the
analogy that bintina has also been using
so you have the little stake
in the ground and then you have the
little rubber band
attached to the stake and then when
you're
very far away
in the illusion
following the primal limbic algorithmic
will with the mind the rubber bands way
out here and you're getting these
suffering sort of snaps and then
when the rubber band is right next to
this
stake in the ground this is when you're
flowing more with that dao you're
flowing more
with love yes with light the sentinel
intelligence with the central
intelligence so just to climb foreign
because like to give a little context
the stick
the stick represents the human being in
that analogy
and the rubber band is the distance from
the source of this intelligence
so the distance is basically the
distance
of the of the wheel the when the wheel
is given
away to to the faults to the antler to
the program
it generates imbalance
this harmony distance from this tooth
which is balance and harmony
and this intelligence two emotions
which in this analogy development
that the tension in life
its emotions what we call emotions this
energy
this emotion energy emotion
the contracting
emotions the pain is a signal
is in like an alarm system is like
the guidance system the guidance system
a messenger it's like it's a it's
benevolent it's it comes for us to let
us know
something in a painful way sometimes but
with a very loving
foundation and
causality to to wake us up to wake up us
to wake us up to the fact that we are
we got straight from this source from
this intelligence
so then cool we can choose
otherwise we can see it
understand it and choose otherwise so
that you don't
get so far the rubber band from the
source central intelligence and get the
snap of suffering repeatedly yeah
okay yes and true otherwise so the
choice
it begins again with the mind but with
the deepening
it's being revealed this free will is
actually
another award for free awareness
free awareness free awareness free will
in that case in the deepest
sense and essence of this concept
free will is free awareness interesting
so
none equals free awareness equals
freeware so non-algorithmic
non-primal non-limbic non-reactive
non-egotistical non-contract contract
non-contract contracted
sense of identity beautiful the the free
will
is where we locate we are free to locate
a sense of identity wherever we want so
we can locate it
in the world in objects in
a partner in a bank account
in the mind in the body or we can locate
it in a
to nature which is interesting flawless
boundless
all-pervasive
client awareness love light
which is here now always which is that
which is
enabling this experience that which is
enabling
us sitting here and speaking and you're
sitting and listening and
navigating in this world it's that which
is here now
in the root in the center of
every experience of every perception
it's the very
core
of oneself it's a deeper sense
of oneself the deeper sense of of
me of meanness of highness of existence
of awareness and the real
interesting the deepest sense
of the very ines is
the free agency
to identify when the
emotional guidance system is
creating catalysts for one to
do the self-inquiry yeah that's one way
to
get to use it and to reflect to it cool
cool yeah and
very very important one yeah the
emotional system but in general that's
the gateway to the truth of liberation
to to
love this
pure presence this pure i this the
innermost sense of
eye of me of me so
you can we can we can step into it now
tune into it now
like a little example
to begin with like um
if i tell you to raise your hand
yeah you do it right why was in the left
instead of the right yeah it doesn't
matter like your left your left hand
or to lift something with your hand okay
so
you okay you pick up the phone but why
the phone how do you do it
how do you do it i do it yeah
yeah how no how how did you pick up the
phone
using will yeah i mean simple words you
just wanted to do it yeah
you when you want to do when you have to
do something you do it how you do it
you don't know you just do it because we
wanted to do it
right we don't think about it but it's
this is how it works
it's very like it's unconscious but how
do we walk
because we want it to work we don't
think about it no
it's it's innate it's inherent in us
in the same way
[Music]
in the spiritual journey
in this way of knowing oneself deeply
the essence of oneself is the same
principle the way to tap into this
free awareness
this in the sense of i am-ness
of meanness of the core of a being
which there lies
peace and harmony and bliss and love
and confidence the way is to
simply wanting it
wanting wanting it yes it's like
desiring awakening
or desiring one's true nature to know
thyself
yes but but also here and now how do you
tap into this
in a more sense of me you just step into
it
will for it yes will for the i am yes
just here and now can you know it
you can you can tap into it because you
know it it's it's you it's in you
it was never a part of you
it is covered by thoughts and
desires and motivations and other
priorities but
this is the this is the message it's
always here
yeah and always accessible yeah even if
not instantly now to pure will
your will to to see it and to know it
will lead you
to information to teachers to
experiences that will
facilitate this deepening this further
uncovering of this innate
free events free will or
original identity original position of
oneself
yeah and then everything because it
becomes lighter you know like
it sucks out the oxygen the energy of
yes yes the thousands and thousands of
like
programs that the trial runs around you
know around the head and
morning to evening and then the center
becomes more and more like the
the pool becomes more and more the
central presence yeah
stability and yes one can tap into it
with training with yes also
faith yes by
the way and by just having it
just knowing it is here yes and
abiding you know abiding and
and and yeah and just letting just sort
of like also surrendering and
surrendering yeah yeah it's like
yeah it's part of the journey too like
let let let this river not the river of
the of the samsara the river of the dow
the river of tus
take you it's anyway it's also it's
like you could say it's parallel to the
river from the river of the dao the
river the tooth so
you choose to jump to get yourself out
of this river and
relocate in the in the river of joy
and sometimes you need to do it again
and again again because you pivot
they can force from here and there so
the river of the doubt the legal tools
the bliss is also
is on anyway the case always so that's
also the the
all of the will to
like sink back with this
tool yes to come back so to speak
although we never really leave it but
yeah
so to speak that's the primary
functionality is the
absolutes gps callback
yes that's the gravitational pull the
gravitational pull
first to it and that's good that's good
to connect
and to install this magnet
yeah i like that by this uh that's
that's beautiful so it's it's almost
like moving
away from the scripts especially of the
matrix
especially of these most limbic or
primal
programs
and like you said
creating a magnet in the i am
and then abiding and recalling to that
like doing the repetitions in the gym
lifting weights
or when you shoot the three-pointers in
basketball or you play the instrument
you do the repetitions and then it
becomes a natural
state yes it becomes effortless then yes
and so you're just
constantly then in the natural state
yeah with the we would say with practice
and
integration it's
usually like you shift back and forth
like
the more natural state and the more
conditioned state
but yeah the will is the iron yeah
essentially cool
cool and and which is god and is the
pool
yes which is god also so yeah will is
god
god is like this omnipresent omniscient
science
omni like all pervasive
[Music]
eternal infinite force power
perfect so
the will
and don't take my word i invite you to
go into experimenter to exploit the
wheel is
also stands for this principle
the will when when seen as awareness is
free awareness
is this a formless point of
focus which is not really a point it's
everywhere yeah
it's everywhere and it's timeless yeah
but
it is it can be seen also as a point of
attention
although it's also the they all feel the
whole
view yes not only the point of view it
can be a point of view
but it can be the view itself the
vastness of
infinite potential so the timeless and
the formless
will is what
is the navigating force in the
creative process yes both
both the navigating forces and the
enabling forces and enabling the
the origination point of all perception
and of all times and in a human being
that's the precious faculty that's the
precious
gift and tool so to speak
to establish in this truth to
be an example to others to cultivate
compassion
yeah and wisdom
and balance them and just have fun also
in in a harmonious way and
extract lessons and value from
experiences
not only chasing them and yes
losing oneself within them so we'll
we'll this has been so beautiful we'll
we'll wrap here
um let's let's just wrap by
saying that we'll hear your
tennis ball back on this
endlessly
we undergo a process of
play of exploration of
creativity where we
place ourself into this
dream that
serves us in getting to know
ourselves better through an endless
possibility of ways to play
and that we use will
to enable that to navigate it and to be
as we become more vigilant
we can navigate it more harmoniously
more in love more in light more in the
natural
state exactly and more in acceptance
which is another
key element and that's a perhaps
structure by itself but
that's also a gateway to acceptance it's
a good point
yes seeing like
i am choosing i am enabling whatever i
see whatever experience in you and
everyone
it's like taking responsibility not
not as bad and not as like oh i'm
responsible for it like
with my conscious mind but thank but as
as the awareness as this enabling factor
it's it's helping one acknowledge and
and see that you are always
choosing what you experience
yeah maybe not consciously maybe it's
not what you prefer
with your conscious mind with your
personal mind with your separate mind
but
essentially if we realize free awareness
enables all the experiences no
nothing could be experienced without it
so
when it's seen directly and clearly
that's that generates an automatic
acceptance of oneself
and of experiences of circumstances
events
and then freeze the energy and freeze
the
attention to focus on growth
on learning on expansion yeah service
yes yes beautiful on opening up for more
of oneself for love
so so yeah acceptance here is another
key element that
the this understanding that's small
balance and true understanding of this
free will
helps us tap into
acceptance of oneself it's a crucial
crucial
yeah yeah that's like it's number two
know yourself
accept yourself become the creator yeah
acceptance is
mission critical from yeah it's the
dance
i love it uh very last quick question
what
is most beautiful
what is most beautiful
to open the heart to the possibility
of the absolute perfection
of this reality of this life of this
existence and to to our role
in it of every action of every move
everything we do the significance
and the beauty and the this
the base of it which is love
so want to open the heart do it more and
more and more
step by step yes that's that's beautiful
that's amazing to see it
within myself within others
yeah so this dance this
transformation that cyclically
plays yeah so all you can say very
in my world what's really for this dance
the dance advancement yeah and the
transformative process
opening the heart itself to that
infinite perfection
i love that you're recognized
yeah yeah yeah you know yeah
yeah yeah because you're right the heart
opening
has been just
thank you for the show the episode thank
you
thank you thank you you're beautiful
i'm calling myself beautiful
yeah this was so nice i'm so grateful we
got to meet and
do this we love you all very much thank
you thanks for tuning in
we're so grateful we would love to hear
from you in the comments below
let us know how you feel feel free to
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe if you haven't already
share the video with people that you
feel like it would bring value to
and that's all
we adore you infinitely thanks for
tuning in
leverage some of the things that gillard
was sharing with us
the show goes on the show goes on the
[Music]
dance